[Music]
here's how the his on the survey works
we asked three celebrities to complete a
phrase our first phrase was Arnold
Schwarzenegger taking over Celebrity
Apprentice is Sylvester Stallone said a
surprising career move by an old friend
Donald Trump said a worthy successor to
my legacy
NBC chairman Bob Greenblatt said an
impossible challenge for the
closed-captioning industry little
goalless please no snap low down in the
sheets what I love thinking of him
giving the assignment a favorite thing
if I step out of the presidential race
it will be because John Kasich wrote my
numbers are just too low
Scott Walker said I'd rather throw my
weight behind another candidate Lindsey
Graham said I'm a man named Lindsey my
first job my first job was Jake
Gyllenhaal said working in a restaurant
bussing tables Jennifer Aniston said
working at a movie theater taking
tickets Kim Davis said working at a
candy store stopping people from buying
Mike and Ikes
she's very passionate on that subject oh
yeah Mike shall not lay with Ike it's in
the Bible kids people tell me I look a
lot like Joe Biden said my father
Carly Fiorina said my grandmother Ted
Cruz said someone took the comedy and
tragedy masks and melded them together
[Applause]
the best website for meeting women is
dave Franco said match.com Seth Rogen
said a harmony calm
Chris Hemsworth said I am Chris
Hemsworth my supporters are Bernie
Sanders said young and progressive ben
Carson said religious and conservative
Rick Santorum said Kevin and delaying
one unique talent I have is that I can
Kristin Chenoweth wrote play the harp
Colin Hanks wrote step dance Tommy Lee
Jones said kill plants with my frown
could be a 1000 year old redwood yeah I
have faced I've faced a lot of
discrimination as was before and said a
woman Marco Rubio said a cuban-american
bobby jindal said a cartoon cricket he's
got Pinocchio's vote every day I say to
my wife Tom Hanks said I love you that's
very nice iced tea said I can't imagine
life without you Bill Clinton said if
there's a scrunchie on the doorknob
please not I knew I was getting older
when Harrison Ford said I needed my
glasses to see my clock Betty White said
I got winded walking up one flight of
stairs Larry King said I had trouble
hearing the Big Bang
yeah hey thanks for watching be sure to
click subscribe to see even more great
Conan clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography